bird brains are tiny the common pigeons
is about the size of a peanut but having
smaller noggins doesn't mean birds are
unintelligent
one way scientists estimate brain power
is through the number of neurons present
some birds have upwards of one to two
billion
similar to monkeys the intelligence of
birds from new zealand parrots that
understand probability
to ravens that can plan for the future
isn't a surprise to researchers who have
long seen their
capabilities early models proposed that
only a small region of birbanes was
responsible for complex behaviors
but this has been revised in recent
years
still the detailed internal organization
of bird brains hadn't been explored
until now
two new studies in science dig into
their structure and function
revealing even greater similarities to
mammalian brains
researchers shine different angles of
light into extremely thin slices of the
pallium
the area of the bird brain with a
similar function to the neocortex of
mammals
this allowed them to see a 3d view of
the fibers that connect neurons
the fibers of owls and pigeons were
organized much like those of mammals
parallel fibers along the pallium were
cross cut by perpendicular fibers
between
layers forming columns of connection
these micro circuits could explain how
birds are capable of complex behaviors
like newly discovered conscious
experiences
researchers tested whether crows are
aware of what they see
and do first they train two crows to
indicate
whether they saw a faint light a dark
gray dot on a black background
after they flashed the dot and showed
the rule for that round which varied to
prevent the birds from preparing their
responses
they asked the crows to report what they
saw because the dot was hard to make out
from the background
the crows sometimes failed to report
accurately
instead they had to decide whether they
perceived a dot or not
researchers inserted electrodes into the
crow's brains to monitor how hundreds of
neurons responded during this exercise
when the crows indicated that they saw a
stimulus hundreds of neurons fired
before they made their selection
those same neurons were silent when the
birds demonstrated that they didn't see
the faint dot
this response shows that the activity of
birds represents
more than what they see adding them to
the animals capable of conscious thought
although the most recent common ancestor
of birds and mammals was alive about 320
million years ago
both these studies show striking
similarities between their brain
capabilities
bird brain may soon become an insult of
the past